ah God it feels good to be a gangster
let's do this
last I heard we're on that and then let
a cow that let me translate on there we
go to my face a little mark some people
are starving to death and it's not
really my problem but you know like I'm
a gentleman so let me just gentlemen
these people up broke when can thank you
no thank you yes this certainly will not
do this will not do okay at where we had
gone today to hit a Marilyn edge as a
say here yeah take some of that scene I
why not you know and I made that now I
don't need that either
my back is like Don Ernie what the heck
is what does what is that he's a water
how do I get on water now once again I'm
what I get at that guy
oh man this guy calls really good up
there okay I gave him water sir I guess
it's bleeding oh it just means he's
bleeding he's a little high gray he's
fine sorry your head a little messed up
crap I gotta fix si
okay
and this pickle are on their way out
he'll tap way long for me to be swift my
route tab
why were you going in the a now I don't
need this
[Music]
taxes at Hannah
oh that's all the jalapeño here yes
punch
alright
Shosh show and to warn you there rumors
that there will be an inspection
insulation problem goes up shake this
shotgun ammo half okay a lotta that look
great
oh you're up on us yeah yeah yeah go
belly punch huh
well belly punch for you dad I hear
something over there I'm not calling on
that for a while okay we'll check down
here nothing in here just a waste of
time
yes way so matter of time okay can I go
on that now
what kind of key doesn't like disappears
pretty dope
okay hello Zach what the tank is this
dead dad you know it's like a zombie
invasion huh huh
ah nice max perfect perfect I love stuff
in here that's for sorry okay which one
my supposed to be gone
that's house the way I guess not
did I skip something let me go back real
quick we have quite guys real quick sir
can I help you oh I can go up some
people are fighting lines for some site
work okay
the heck is on on-air
mmm-hmm pretty good there mother I got a
met that's got on over here
oh oh and um fell okay I mean I'm going
like really far away from where I am
don't forget to put a lock on the door
people need to get past at the warehouse
wait what tax going on why they're two
minutes so that finding so yeah I did
that girl out there
now what that working at is again let's
get back out of here so it sucked
eight five eight four then I got a lot
of people afraid though you know a lot
of people to fit in with our live man
once I find it you can mail it games
like ten times easier okay there I got
that there you go
cept yeah I go here we go coming
I'm telling sir here people up to a
don't you yeah people start and I love
to it let's about your son this guy so I
got healed
not crap yeah right yep yep
I say I'm a mechanic yes
yeah doulas I can't go I will tell live
here at 1:00 hang in there I look at
this cuz I was way out there how it was
there what the heck I got off the grid
this guy's I was going out
oh my god
that all right
by God hey I'm not telling to up
overheating or something right
he'll get the hell off of here man they
using all my stuff yeah I just want to
lock what's going on here
hello sir
[Music]
all right
he's got red eyes
dang is s
okay
do they still myself gray I got I got
like ten miles away well well change it
what's going on here to take my train
that took my train good day alright just
wastin everyone's time that someone's
gonna not make it
hmm but Kelly that guy his head down to
his own gun how much I got one and what
I can't his and they're going to make
some tough decisions here then this
vampire is on his way out
stop the train place what the heck is
this
what
like I went down
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I gotcha bro
say by the time they're without that
that man that dr. hack alright can I
make my health dance oh yeah
let the crap some items
well they're fooling around I want to
make some Maxo real stuff you know make
some real stuff okay here's the one that
actually I need fed desk I actionaid fit
oh my god they all they said hi we're
here the hell this place
yeah well I got some fat okay whoo cash
flows down there rappers
whoo
sorry brows we gotta look out for number
one here
how do I take in this thank you up and
it's just that okay and hold off on that
one
there's that here another trainer back
o'clock F this James to campus how about
that may not
now back check that was all the way
happened
that's pressure
yeah yeah I like that
look how handle things back there LAPD
style tapped up that is how I get
and hey those take that wrong and I got
the port let's down here just up with
this power supply now
hey I did that like that
let's gone out here
side then I and I have you out here and
I get J what you Nana okay I'll send up
huh
okay I said well my bag read you got toe
feds and to Mad Catz
I got a head of software and his
offering okay Mad Catz Mad Catz
huh there is okay first I said
they died
I can't tell I know this plans about the
shutdown
come on come on yes right yeah oh you're
not so good I have to last event
come on all right okay I'm mad okay hey
yeah make it madness I kind of had it
make it it uh well I tried
all right shot mm-hmm and as I say here
tickets will be refunded if there's a
problem there's no problem yeah Tina
right still ahead comes out this guy's
going off a long haul i Riddick Jesus
come on I hope this guy's will stop yet
that he is on I dry up yeah after we met
at hand
yes yes yes dad okay then I tried sorry
I slipped okay okay what is it snow
yetis yes they're better yet
okay it's over here
stay in the game last let's shoot break
that one do it again
okay I've said that up
hey car
ooh pastor alert extended clip this is
what I read
because I might as well to get this and
how long I go in this place send it
again it's not bad at this time hello
where am I going
again
who's that guy man Jesus okay let me get
back out of here
hello sir
okay 3 10 10 3
that's not a shine to the I'm wearing
James
hello sorry that's not really a
fantastic what is this
and it any idea
it's a statement hi Graham mouw's how
about that but I talking about
tefik ahem just sign it off
right
messed up and I got okay wearing on that
now what's up
what's a dehl hair okay like that
so it's gone on this uh-huh
let me get some firewood just to go
typical bureaucratic maths and it's just
it's a taxpayers money you know hello
Birds I'm glad you're safe help lend a
firewood it's gone out here oh yeah you
like that
I got punch but it's fine a man can take
a punch
a man can't a guy botched
how to make a tie in pipe bags and that
about ten minutes
what's okay now II actually hurt my
what the heck is that
oh my god protect your pipes right
do-do-do-do-do-do - walking through the
pies failure yeah just walking through
the pipes with a toilet yeah okay see
what's going on over here
so I've gotten over half
like that and I can punch the stomach
wall butter sauce little belly on it
that's the whole idea
like that okay
he died because they're not a lot
[Music]
right Picasso
alright say what gun on a
this is a better track
hate those things
stupid egg no entry
honey can pick up the stuff now crap
right right right right right
step it about it and stamp it about it
sekarang glue the hang of that Oh
stare spell
okay so I'll talk about that's why I did
what I do you know
okay
how do I open a star
shave
and mess with the past I like the rest
you know how do they 7i thread okay I
probably this upside here you know you
know seven eight
all right let's let's get out of here
otherwise I got my bottom hand side down